back to our interview with Kim
Kardashian West because we just had to
know what she thought of her mom's cameo
in ariana grande's thank you next music
video and our lauren zima got a scoop
can we speak on Kris Jenner in the thank
you next video she came to lunch that
day and was just showing us over and
over and we're like mom we'd love it
you're iconic but we've seen it like a
hundred times it's so funny even that
Victoria's Secret clip of Kendall she
was doing the same exact thing in the
audience thank you next well cool mom's
running the Kardashian family just check
out Kim getting a makeover from
five-year-old daughter North I think the
foundation has to go everywhere though
is she a beauty mogul in the making I
actually had to put her on our PR list
and get her her own set of makeup this
time her new favorite thing ever is
closing the door with one of her friends
or her dolls and doing makeovers we
caught up with Kim this morning at the
launch of her new k'kaw beauty and
fragrance pop-up where Kim staff is clad
in Yeezy designs courtesy of hubby Kanye
it's part makeup counter and part art
installation and it's just in time for
holidays I love love love my concealers
I'm excited that you can test it all out
here
Kim also told us that the famous
Kardashian Christmas card hasn't been
shot yet but she has a plan for this
year is the first year that Kanye and I
are taking over the Christmas Eve party
but I think if I have a photographer
waiting you might be able to pull up a
really late Christmas card maybe a New
Year's card that works I mean like you
just have to watch her like she's so
professional I'm taking this and they
put Kanye in the Christmas car yeah
you